thank you
[Music]
all right
do you guys want me to tell you anything
or do you just want to see what it is
yes all right but don't tell me
oh
my God
to me would be a 3D animated cartoon
series designed for kids I say
preschoolers Toddlers and eventually
kids of all ages because it's so
influential oh they're all dogs I get it
I get it they're all dog isn't it crazy
that he was like a freaking like almost
got convicted from murdering [ __ ] and
now he's like not Glenn that's what I'm
saying
I love forever get that pass bro dude
Snoop is my hero man hey if anyone could
make a cool kid show it's Snoop so
that's a kid's show it's a new series
that uh snoops come out with where it's
it's um yeah it's a series of children's
songs and nursery rhymes let's go that's
so cool see once he already did his [ __ ]
with [ __ ] Martha Stewart
that's kind of changed it for you that's
when it's like he could do anything he
became a brat like a household I feel
like he became Untouchable at that point
yeah I was like no [ __ ] because it's
redundant you can't say nothing against
it now because it's like he beat
everybody to that punch yeah of like
imagine one of these songs just to hear
the lighter
all right the wheels on them
that's a bunch
ES
I feel like um ice cube was one of the
first like dudes of that era to to to do
all the like Daddy Day Care or like
whatever wait yeah yeah those kid movies
but he's still Ice Cube though he's
still mad because I was like okay
um and then so like it's not that
surprising that all these guys grew and
then they're like not just a gangster
rapper I mean that's the I think that is
the key though is there's a lot of
comedy and juxtaposition and you can't
just get a guy who's a tough guy has a
joke no like you're taking the guy from
boys in the hood and you're making him
goofy yeah that's pretty crazy but it's
also like you know their their brands
change over time you can't it's like you
said you can't expect to be the same
person your whole [ __ ] life yeah and
it's cool to see them yeah man that's
that's really dope because that he's
doing a kids show it almost seems
arguably more fun and easier when you
start bad rather than like people that
go bad yeah yeah because that's like
that's a bad story you know what I mean
the other one's a rags to riches but
sometimes it could be done so like like
uh it could be it can make you look like
a total sellout isn't that weird so
sensitive like or you just look like oh
that's pretty funny actually I think
when you're young you think guys like
that are sellouts I think the older you
get you realize that it's like dude go
[ __ ] yourself also to be fair though
Snoop has always notoriously been the
dude who will grab any bag he'll go into
like a a random person's [ __ ]
Hispanic music video where like nobody
knows but it's because there was a
Payday and he's like I'm gonna jump in
here and I'm gonna do here's his new
limpia La Casa
there's like a meme going around about
how Snoop will do anything for the bag
and he was just doing all these random
things like that Korean music video he's
in he did a Vietnamese music video
wasn't there a story that he would do a
verse for like 10 G's or some [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] I think he said that yeah he said
that right I think I remember people say
that yeah that's like part of his brand
then that stays in that path of
Untouchable you can't knock a guy for
anything anymore because he's making
himself relevant Yeah by being
everywhere and he's willing to do like
not cool things yeah but because he
makes it cool yeah I will say good he's
in that new movie I was talking about
and he does really good in it it's
called day shift yeah okay he's like a
pretty big character in it too and he
does really good yeah it wasn't the
first one that came out was it training
day or baby boy
because I was a car wash wasn't even
in costume but the first one when he
came out he was playing that dude on a
wheelchair training day as [ __ ] oh yeah
it was a training date yeah yeah yeah
Denzel makes him throw up the [ __ ]
yeah that was like a big like for me
that was a big oh [ __ ] Snoop Dogg
[ __ ] acting yeah
I like seeing dog acting yeah it seemed
like anything is fun because he's so
himself yeah yeah you know what I mean
he it's impossible for him to suddenly
be some other like very different
character because he's so do you ever
see him on Andy Milonakis show I think
so I would imagine I remember that I
don't I only remember seeing a little
John on any Moon
Andy Milonakis show was so underrated
and too damn early too early yeah too
early so good I ran into him on the
Santa Monica like little thing where
like the rides are and [ __ ] and he was
filming yeah he was filming like for his
twitch and [ __ ] but I was almost like
Starstruck because I'm like [ __ ] I used
to love his show so much as a kid on MTV
too yeah like that show was so [ __ ]
funny religiously loved that show I
still I think I bought it on Amazon you
asked how how goat Snoop is like
he also right he he just did that track
with BTS he did yeah which is like you
know BTS number one [ __ ] K-pop group
or no Jackson
thank you thank you right uh so he does
that but then he's also he was like nft
mobile during that season right he's one
of the first people he was working with
Andy yeah he's doing crazy [ __ ] right he
also performed in like probably one of
the most the best and celebrated Super
Bowl performances halftime shows dude
that Super Bowl performance was so like
just that and now he's coming out with a
kid's Melody and Ron's [ __ ] TV
animated show that at the end of the day
if you're [ __ ] thinking the way he's
probably thinking in his [ __ ]
high-ass business mind that's all just
generated IP he can merge out with
anything from his like merchandise to
nft sales you know what I'm saying it's
all just like animated ipe the guy that
he collabed with for that is also the
dude who created hip-hop Harry who's Hip
Hop Harry oh my God the duty [ __ ]
dancing with the Jabberwockies baby
hip-hop hair is a [ __ ] giant what
like a hamster I don't know what he is I
thought he was a bear bear I don't know
he's just dress all hip-hop and [ __ ] I'm
trying to see Snoop Dogg on that show
Caillou was his name the guy with the
bald head who has cancer he has cancer
in that show no wait no it's like a
conspiracy
Snoop Dogg the conspiracies at Caillou
the whole time is just dreaming
everything he's really in a bed with
cancer oh that's [ __ ] up why why
what did he saying
no yeah I mean is there anything off
limits from what Snoop Dogg can do no no
bro he was a commentator for the [ __ ]
UFC at home Point yeah oh he was a
commentator for the Olympics but Kevin
Hart and then the horse was dead he's
like man look at the horse [ __ ] walk
kill dude everyone loved him like it's
if anything maybe he can't make like a
cat show like that would be weird like a
football coach too isn't he like a
football coach as well for like his kids
football team
yeah yeah I totally see that yeah that's
amazing this guy is so like crazy and
like transcending if he randomly popped
up in an episode of Game of Thrones even
after himself I'd like I think I see it
just the dragon side what up Cub
your car is [ __ ]
it's the roast or something
it's the roast Long Beach wait boys from
the West Side anyway
he was always one side yeah always he
said Long Beach I think all right what's
the next new project that he's gonna do
not Game of Thrones further than this I
don't know [ __ ] open up some
competitor against Kaiser or some [ __ ]
also he did like the the WWE uh e [ __ ]
too remember when he [ __ ] came out
yes does he have any restaurants or
anything oh isn't Andy working online
with them ending to win the guy uh who
used to own Afters is working on a
restaurant project he just did something
with Bun B right across from Sofi
Stadium that's right yeah you could do
he could do anything and that thing is
integrated with crypto or nfts in some
way as well right and he's a grandpa how
old is he now let's check that dude's
age he's he's a he's a he has a grandson
I feel like he never stopped working
man he deserves to work forever man if
he wants to yeah he's gonna be for sure
I feel like 90 of what he is he's doing
is like is no longer working for him
though that's true it feels like uh he
gets to show up as himself in every type
of facet that he does and then it feels
like he only has to do it like in his
Lane yeah you know what I mean even like
him [ __ ] uh commenting for for
peacock on the Olympics like he doesn't
have to play other people's games yeah
it seems like they make the game work
for his personality he he's only 50
years old is he wow
yeah for some reason I thought he was in
his 60s yeah 50. wow that's yeah this
fool is [ __ ] incredible yeah remember
he did the [ __ ] uh Danny also
commentate for the National Geographic
or like yeah like like the animals that
sounds like it makes sense like he had
like a snoop week where he like does his
own commentary like if it wasn't David
Attenborough it should be Snoop Dogg
he's like holy [ __ ] that crocodile ate
the [ __ ] out of that zebra I remember
I've seen I've seen Clips like that I
think I saw one word underwater and
there was like this lizard the one
running right and he's like oh my god
look he's reacting to it I did a soup
dog and oh yeah Snoop Dogg he's a goat
his old school music too is just so good
too I'm glad nothing happened to him
yeah I'll be fine if he like shows up as
a cameo in the MCU
that's who it doesn't matter you know
it's like Harry Styles showing up as
[ __ ] thanos's brother did he really
really his mother Alert in what in
eternals the final credit scene oh [ __ ]
I didn't do any of you exist out of this
room because I left no I left out of the
eternals oh yeah the eternals is the one
with the dude from The Game of Thrones
Rob Stark anyways the very very end
would you be mad if exhibit showed up as
Professor X
he just
[Laughter]